yes I am standing here in front of the
white house I'm about to go speak with
FLOTUS and POTUS right here in
Washington D.B I mean DC
with the Drew Barrymore show
[Music]
would you say
um that you're a good Gift Giver to Dr
Biden has he ever surprised you with
something that really did surprise you
well I one thing that Joe gives me every
year is a poem which is I knew you'd
love that he has a book that he bought
for me and every year he writes a poem
you personally write the poem
of course I do a lot to write about
there's no better present than one
that's made you know the one you can't
buy
but that doesn't quite do it
it helps but I have I really enjoy
shopping for Joe for gifts but uh but he
also gave me a Rose Garden for my
birthday one year a full Rose Garden oh
I love that gift how are you feeling
about your gift this year very good oh
you are but I can't tell her no of
course not but I like that he pretty
much gets it right that's very much gets
it right
that's an eight out of ten oh man
so everybody knows I love her more than
she loved me
oh well I actually need to ask about the
five proposals is it true you proposed
five times and what was it that finally
won her over I don't know what fine I
think I know it finally won her over but
when I when I accidentally lost my first
family part of my first family my first
wife I was put on that 10 most eligible
bachelor's list mm-hmm and some of the
things that came across the wire were
like I had to give the FBI you know
anyway the bottom line was I just given
up on going out with anyone my brother
set us up on a blind date my youngest
brother and uh when I went out for the
first time I knew this was the woman I
really did so you believe in love at
first sight I do on the first night only
twice in my life
have I ever fallen in love and both
times where I knew immediately
I'm not joking I know that sounds
bizarre but I but I once asked her I
said how can you when she finally agreed
to marry me how can you marry me knowing
how much I'd love my first wife she said
because you love that deeply you can
love that way again
I'll never forget that may be real and
by the way you know how we finally got
it yeah what was that what it was my
boys our boys were young and they came
in and I said Dad and Hunt turned the
ball and said Bo you tell them and no
you tell them you'd find I said what's
the matter guys and beaufan said Dad
we're talking we think we should marry
Jill
I swear to God how old were they at this
point they were uh six and seven yeah
but I had to ask her five times I have
the fifth time I was in South Africa
trying to see Nelson Mandela with her
anyway long story I came home we could
still imprisoned
and I came back got off the plane in
Philadelphia drove straight to her
apartment knocked on her said oh Joe
come on in I said no since you've got my
Irish show
I said I'm asking you one more time
and I said you don't have to say when
but if
if you say no I understand and that's it
and I looked at I said will you marry me
she goes
okay
I swear to God
so later after it was all over I called
my sister I said what am I interchanging
why are there friends she said she told
me she fell in love with the boys what
was it that finally said all right this
time it worked well you know I had to
make absolutely sure that this marriage
was going to work because they had lost
their mother and they had lost their
sister
and I knew that
we had it had to work because I had lost
so much and they had to feel secure that
this marriage would work
they fell in love with theirs too I'm
not joking
that's not a joke they decided we should
marry Joe wasn't it wasn't you should
matter we should marry Jill and we got
married at the U.N chapel and in the
chapel while we're sitting there it says
who takes this and both the boys got up
and walked in the old spontaneous came
up onto the altar so we're not married
as a family
no but it wasn't planned it was
spontaneous they both got up and walked
in and we both were were surprised and
pleased and uh we spent our honeymoon
night together all four of us
we went to see them
which is also my best friend
for real
can tell her anything she's got a
backbone like a ramrod
oh she does
you don't want to mess with me with this
woman
and uh give me strength give me humor
and I know we can get somewhere together
so you got both of them I'm usually the
brother humor though and the boys love
her made fun of me
of course they do who wants to grow up
in a serious household I can't make fun
of things and I have so much to work
with
my life in comedy I will either try to
make you laugh or I will be the bread of
the joke as long as people are laughing
I'm happy I prefer it wasn't always
about me though well I've definitely
been the butt of a lot of jokes you know
sometimes I'm watching Saturday Night
Live and I'm like enjoying myself and
lost in it and then I'll come on and
I'll be like well this really breaks
that fourth wall down man all right
and by the way if you can't laugh at
yourself oh my God big trouble
especially in the business we're in
exactly exactly you and me yeah you and
us yeah well I have actually I thought
so much about this um but I love that
you have opened yourself up and given
room and space for people to acknowledge
the real journey of life and for me it
brings me in to the humanity and the
personal more than anybody else and
that's attributed to you too and I thank
you both for that thank you well you
know I uh think of all the people all
the heroes I mean it's from the bottom
of my heart
people say well you went through a lot
the losses you've had Etc but I I was
lucky I had family I got Jill I got her
sister no for no for real I believe for
real
think of all the heroes get up every
morning
every morning put one foot in front of
the other and keep moving keep moving
and they have nobody the staff doesn't
anymore they used to kid me because I I
find myself stopping to talk to people
who you can just tell yes or down yes
and as I came out here in her but it's
not I mean
I think of the people who when things
were really down for me when I got the
news
how how they how they just the little
things the little tiny things just just
reaching out we literally just saying Hi
how are you
um and uh I believe you were that person
I'll tell you a real quick Story one of
the things my dad he was up in
Philadelphia he was in his late 70s he
was still working full-time I went up to
see him I was a U.S senator and I was I
had to be in Philly and we're going to
go to a restaurant to lunch and I had
two of my staff with me were heading to
lunch and then my dad well
and a guy walked across the street and
said hey buddy can you spare a diamond
effect ask for help and I I don't know
why I said it because I had a friend
used to joke and I said I'm working
inside the street
my father stopped dead
the only thing my father never once
raised his hand and it was with a
devastating thing he said to me twice in
my life you disappoint me and he turned
around my dad didn't make money took out
his wallet he had 40 bucks cashing it
and he hands it to the guy and I said
Dad I'm sorry
I can't believe it I can't believe what
you did I can't believe it I said but
daddy is going to go by and he looked at
me and he said do you think he'd be
doing it if he had any other choice he'd
be doing something later that was my dad
and that's the only time my whole life I
would do that I don't know why I did it
maybe you need those moments to just
remind you to keep being that empathic
person you know this holiday season it's
2022 we're coming to the close of a year
a good year a fantastic year a year with
so much hope so much being able to work
the thing that's also so synonymous with
you is to being able to work with
everybody which is so much a part of
what so many of us want and for those
who want that and believe in it you are
a beacon and I've always been a Beacon
of Hope with that some people have
holidays that are difficult some people
reach out just Reach Out
let people know you care about them I
mean bring them literally bring them to
your table I mean exit kindness I mean
it just
it it and it makes it makes a world of
difference
[Music]
well at Mr President and Dr Biden I
actually was wondering if I could play
my favorite game with you on the show
it's called the final five but this is a
very special edition because in this
case Dr Biden has already seen the
questions and she knows what they are so
the question is is Mr President actually
going to get the answers correct all the
little bit of the old Newlywed Game
style would you play with me sure okay
it's the beautiful special edition of
the five okay
[Music]
Jill's favorite room in the house do you
know what it is
actually I don't think it's in the house
it's on the house The Truman balcony I
think
outside looks over the
yo
okey-dokey number one got it number two
when Dr Biden is starving and wants to
be a little naughty what snack does she
get from the White House kitchen
why
I said snack I don't want you to lose
this one I have an act
probably uh
something with avocado in it
french fries oh french fries
consider wine a snack too
who doesn't by the way
Dr Biden has a free Friday night does
she want to go out or stay in
she used to want to go out I think she'd
rather stay in these days
too correct yes and I am with you
I like to stay home and watch movies and
eat take out and be with my animals and
my remote controls and the kids yeah
exactly
um if floaties could change one of your
habits do you know what it would be
so many
I agree with that I don't know what the
hell was the name I think I think one of
the habits would be to uh to not talk to
everybody I see
no
oh that's true he leaves the light on he
wants to he keeps reading
um this is true Mr President can I just
tell you my daughters pulled me aside
the other day and they said could you
stop talking to people as much or if
you're going to because we understand
it's important to you could you edit and
keep it shorter
I've been told that my whole life
you sure so much
my whole life
this was three nights ago so
um the last question is who said I love
you first oh that's easy me I said it
first I said a first second third fourth
fifth sixth eight not ten and it worked
well at Mr um president and um Dr Biden
um I think that it's a good time and a
good year right now and we are going
into the holidays and I'm a voracious
News Junkie and I watch the news every
day all night long I meanter I am so
aware of everything and I feel so good
the marriage equality and you know
bringing Brittany Greiner home the
parties working alongside of each other
an election that was functional and kept
temperatures down I am so excited and
I'm looking back at 2022 with such
fondness and as you're going into 2023 I
just hope for you for the very best and
I thank you for creating feeling around
for everybody give me more credit than I
deserve but thank you well it's how I
truly feel and I'm honored to have the
opportunity to tell you that thank you
so much for your time I don't want to go
may I just quickly point something out
and ask a question which is I think I
see some of that Ivory Snow and I've
been waiting to clock it is that the
stuff it looks similar but that's not
the stuff I think that's from below the
trees here you're right okay but I am
looking out for the Biden snow it is a
Biden tradition that I'm married into
and so
um Joe takes Ivory Snow and mixes it
with water with my electric mixer by the
way and it gets the right consistency
and then he carefully
places it on all the bowels of the tree
so we're going to the Blue Room I'm so
excited to see it well this room is the
Blue Room of course and this is the
official White House Christmas tree and
I wanted it to be a symbol of unity and
hope so if you look closely you can see
every state and every bird was handmade
feel this
is this each of the state bird yes each
state bird oh this is so beautiful as we
go into the next room you're going to
show me the state dining room right yes
wait till you see what we've done I
can't wait well this is we the people
that's the theme I wanted visitors and
people who come at Christmas to see
their Reflections that of of themselves
that's why there's so many
mirrors everywhere and in the balls and
you can see the mirrors in the trees so
that people can see themselves
because I wanted to reflect the values
that Americans have you know like unity
and faith and optimism so I hope that
people see themselves in the people's
house in the decorations I have to say
of all the Christmas tree ideas that
I've ever seen in my life I have to say
your original idea of mirrors is the
coolest thing I've ever seen and I will
never forget it
oh here we sent an invitation to every
state teacher of the year
to ask their students to draw
reflections of themselves
self-portraits from all over our country
oh I love this one Scarlett age six
Georgia okay I am having another wow
moment because this is a play on the
mirrors yeah but it's another extension
of yes that is the most powerful theme
I've ever seen on a Christmas tree well
I hope the visitors who come too
the White House feel the same way so
I feel like I want to have my daughters
will you call yourself portrait and if
you'll send it to me I will put it on
our tree are you kidding me yeah of
course
speaking of family
we have all the our grandchildren's
stockings up here I love the knit ones
yeah that's really just old school and
yummy it is
foreign
[Music]
house which the White House
has had every year and you can I mean is
it I love look at this
they actually put it so that the lights
shine on the wreath what is it is it
like a meringue or something no this is
actual gingerbread they make it white
this is gingerbread and uh yeah and then
this is like a sugar
cookie dough and you know what this is
Independence all in Philadelphia well
um we are saying bye here I don't want
to say goodbye we'll come back really
yes come back anytime well in the
meantime I will send you my daughter's
portraits and all I want is for your
family to have the most beautiful happy
healthy humorous Christmas
well
happy holidays everyone we make this
show for you
I personally want to deliver something
positive optimistic and be a bright spot
just for you
[Music]
[Applause]
we've got more news and it's all about
health and wellness yes are you ready
Ross you go you know I'm ready
you always are ready for health and
wellness well I wasn't always ready for
health and wellness but you know I I
struggle I always say I should be a
weight detective because whenever I lose
it I can always find it again you know I
have I have been up and down and up and
up and up and you know I went on this
health journey and I've been in it and
steady for about three years now feeling
strong and trying to figure out day by
day I haven't drank alcohol in three
years girl hey
and it just you know it's like just
sometimes you're just like I can't I
gotta you know change yeah you have to
figure it out it's one of the things
that comes with adulthood I think if you
paid attention you learn from what
you've been through for me it was losing
my parents and realizing like man I I
want to be here as long as I can and
anything I can do to make that happen
I'm in the fight I am absolutely
and for me it was my kid yeah right I
wanted to be the kind of mom I expected
myself to be for them yeah it's you
gotta figure out what it is for you oh I
love you so much we love you I love you
and also it's like the struggle is real
girl anyone who doesn't like act like
that or acts like they've got it all
together well I don't relate to you so
first up in our news should you judge a
book by its buyer's cover the New York
Post reports that a woman named Cara
placed an order with a local bookstore
and received a wellness check that's
right when bookstore employee Morgan
Hawley filed Cara's order which was
Jeannette McCurdy's emotional Memoir I'm
glad my mom died and Phoebe Waller
Bridges comedic but dark fleabag the
scriptures she included a personal
check-in email saying quote I would say
happy reading but these titles indicate
otherwise hope you're doing okay
should we take a page from this
employee's book well I think it's sweet
I mean these are some dark books she was
reading or at least dark titles you know
so I think it's sweet that Holly was
just checking in on her and I do think
about that sometimes who like the what
they must be thinking when they package
your order like my last Amazon order was
a digital scale and two things of
sugar-free Metamucil
well Ross is having a real party you
know either that or you're on your way
to a colonoscopy
which fun fact about colonoscopies
they're awesome really
you lose three pounds and get a free
Twilight I am telling you
this is my kindness oh hilarious um here
how many people would think like oh
that's nice if somebody sent them an
email like that
just checking in I see one
if if you bought some like alternative
reading and somebody was like you okay
just checking in how would you feel I
would I would appreciate it oh you would
I would I would really appreciate it
yeah oh why may I ask
um because life's hard
life is hard it's hard yeah
someone's just checking on you yeah the
struggle is real yeah it's real it's
real what's your name Cody
hi Cody how you doing today just
checking out I'm good I'm good
I appreciate you Ross I appreciate you
Cody did you come in wearing the company
swag I did I bought it just for you yeah
thank you Cody
okay because a part of me would read
that woman's email and be like
go away like what I'm so sorry I was
buying books not a friend yeah like
that's so weird because I'm rebellious
and like suspicious you know
um
I I do think your perspective is like
gonna shift mine because I do like being
checked on too yeah everyone deserves to
be checked on them yeah all right I
think I learned a lesson I did too thank
you Cody
love that oh I really wasn't expecting
that from this story I was gonna gripe
about This Woman's like over involvement
and now Cody I'm like you're right we're
all let's be open to connection yeah
thank you Cody Ross you're a little real
life health and wellness thanks Cody all
right next up Elite Daily reports that
cuddling may just improve your health
hey cuddle buddies and there's science
behind it they say cuddling release is
something called oxytocin which is a
hormone that makes you feel happy and
comfortable like look who's over here
for a little cuddle
[Applause]
um well research also shows that half an
hour half an hour oh but I'm cuddling uh
can I can cut the amount of stress and
hormones circulating in your body by
half do you cuddle for half an hour no
that's too long no my my arm would go
numb after 20. it was things would get
weird right yeah but this is nice to
cuddle more often I know it's funny too
like I'm single a pandemic you know you
you do start to like really lose
physical contact luckily for me I have
these two delicious kids that I treat
like little human ribs and I yeah
you know yeah oh okay well I cuddle with
them all the time all right well we need
more cuddle breaks in the show I just
want to say that felt nice oh yeah me
too but you know it wouldn't be uh
health and wellness if we didn't get a
little exercise in right uh well if
you're an 80s kid kid like Drew you guys
remember Jazzercise oh yes my mom used
to Jazzercise oh yeah yeah well
according to Desert news it's not just
your mom's workout anymore the 80s
aerobics craze is as popular as ever
thanks to online classes and of course
Tick Tock so my question to you
Barrymore should we Jazzercise
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Cody come here
[Applause]
get between us ready
[Applause]
come on Cody all right after the break
we're gonna teach Champions
don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
a gal or a guy everyone could use some
eyebrow know-how and we're about to help
two of you feel less brow beaten and
joining us as one of our viewers who
happens to know the lyrics to every
single biggie song that's her fun fact
that stay-at-home mom Joelle
um all right why do you feel Joelle that
you needed some eyebrow assistants well
after my pregnancy I had some hair loss
my hair my eyebrows my hair came back on
my head my eyebrows not so much so it's
pretty much the only makeup I wear I'm a
stay-at-home mom with my four-year-old
so I need something fast easy and yeah
all right well do you mind if I attack
your bra please all right so I'm gonna
raise you up if that's okay don't step
off the chair first okay and I think I
can pump this up a little bit I think oh
wow okay let's see okay sorry I'm by the
way I know I'm like no I'm definitely
here we go throughout the segment's
going a little different than how we
thought
ah now all right hello
all right let me see you here okay
I want to make sure that this I really
need glasses too does anyone have the
glasses box
um at the news desk there might be two
readers in there
see I think that color is a little warm
for you yeah this is this is I think a
better tone
all right now this brow actually we made
it Flower Beauty the beauty brand that I
do and it's called the skinny and what I
love about it is you can see how micro
pencil oh my God now it's on you can see
me hi here I am oh that is so different
it's called The Skinny because what it
does is each stroke that you do is gonna
be sort of about as fine as an actual
hair when you get those big chunky
pencils that's not what hair looks like
so what I like about a micro pencil is
it's just gonna go really thin line and
really sparse just the same way our hair
functions
see this is helping now what I like
about this topper the fiber fix is it's
got a liquid and a spoolie so what it's
going to do is it's going to kind of
lock in and raise the hairs up above the
pencil and fluff them up and give it
Dimension because pencils are going to
look flat
they're going to look more on the skin
and this is going to raise those hairs
and make them present
I'm going to make it work
so really I just want to do this really
on the quick because if we spend too
much time it's going to stop you from
doing it
all done
don't want to pluck one hair but I swear
this one I feel like I wish I had no I
saw it this morning
and what's great is once you find a line
that you like that you feel comfortable
with you go ahead and you take a little
baby scissor don't pluck it out you need
the hair it's like a comb over you know
what you know what I mean oh yeah
you know we gotta
not pretend like it's all perfect right
out of the gate sometimes we just need
to give ourselves maybe that's the key
to self-care it's just doing whatever it
takes to make us feel good about
ourselves all right what do you think
this is just one brow real simple I
didn't tweeze I didn't I didn't it looks
good really yeah and natural which is
he's alive
that's easy
[Music]
okay I barely used anything right I
think you look so beautiful and nothing
about this looks painted on or
fraudulent or overdone up in fact you
can wear a no makeup makeup or no makeup
at all and they are not going to
juxtapose each other right feel good
yeah I like it all right
thank you
[Music]
now we could do a little day tonight if
we want
I'm I'm in your ear hole that's okay you
did you think I would be in your earfuls
well I'm feeling really good about this
but as what really matters is how you
feel I feel good right okay I feel good
I'm all up in your business that's all
right how I want it that's okay I have a
four-year-old if you need to throw a
little day to night look yeah what do
you think
I'm
stunning stunning I'm going to do the
other side while we go to commercial
break and I heard also that your husband
is it true that you guys like haven't
gone on a date in a while yeah in like
two years
so that said would it be okay if we sent
you guys on a romantic night on the town
to the most iconic New York City
restaurants sure Cavern on the green wow
yes all right I'm gonna do that other
brow and up next check out this viewers
before photo we tamed his brows
backstage this is Kenny and we gave him
a whole new look and the big reveal is
right after the break
[Music]
we're tackling all of your eyebrow
Beauty questions I'm here with Kenny a
firefighter who fun fact loves to cook
the meals for his fellow firemen oh my
God I love you and whose wife Bambi and
daughter Kendall begged us to give him a
man bro makeover now
all right we're gonna take a look at
Kenny's eyebrows before
now Bambi you say that Kenny's eyebrows
are out of control is this true those
eyebrows after the LA after let's say
after 50 started having a mind of their
own growing this way that way that
direction and pretty soon I was going to
be married to Sam the freaking Eagle
Sam the Eagle I wanted to and she knows
I wanted to at night start plucking the
white ones out I figured though he might
wake up while he was sleeping I know
let's do it
but she had a better idea streams happen
oh yeah I even suggested taking scissors
to his eyebrows in his sleep but you
might poke an eye out well he has two
eyes that's you
you're my kind of ladies for sure well
are you ready to see Kenny's new look
are you
guys
I feel five years younger I was
incredible it makes you look a little
you know since Bambi's been 39 for just
a little while longer now it looks like
we match
how do you feel about yourself I feel
great this uh actually you look in the
mirror and you say wow I remember
feeling this way feeling younger a
little ego boost a little more strength
more energy this is nice did the Brows
bother you before uh I just didn't pay
attention I'd throw glasses over the top
and not look and now and now
guess what I think I might get them done
[Applause]
it looks amazing I bowed down to you
oh I'm so glad that you like it gosh and
you didn't even have to do surgery or
anything like women do all this cosmetic
stuff in your wow
we have this color so we'll send you
home with it so that you can continue to
use it it's easy it's one step you match
it boom bang bang done again if it's not
easy and simple sometimes you will use
Escape avoidance and you won't deal with
it so let's just make it simple okay
little things can have a big impact
definitely okay Dandy and Kendall thank
you so much Kenny we're gonna send you
guys Tavern on the Green
yeah
[Applause]
thank you so much for more brow tips and
a behind the scenes look at Kenny's
makeover go to our Tick Tock it's a Drew
Barrymore show and up next have we been
recycling paper wrong I think I have oh
my gosh Danny Co is here to help us do
it right we'll be right back
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we are all trying to be a little Greener
these days or a lot Greener and
environmental Guru and vegetarian since
the age of 12 Drew crew member Danny SEO
has a quick tip on the right way to
recycle paper this is in a minute go
Danny all right so we all need to
recycle right I am actually really
excited about this because I'm a paper
person and a magazine junkie I'm not
super digital so go get this magazine my
favorite magazine it's everywhere thank
you and so is your magazine Drew so two
little editors here but here's the thing
with paper guys you need to recycle
paper but we have to do it right without
contaminating the paper or recycling
step number one if you use a paper
shredder don't use a shredder unless
it's for confidential Docker which are
things you really want shredded for
everyday things like junk mail gift wrap
you know and even well not my magazine
but I like
other any other magazine but our
magazines just keep them whole crumble
them up you don't have to shred it all
the time if it's not important because
this way we can make sure the paper is
getting recycled properly and things
like this
when you put something like this with
plastic envelopes or Shredder that can
contaminate an entire load of recyclable
paper then it all goes to the landfill
so would this be okay to recycle as is
what you do is you take out this the
plastic part
recycle the paper Parts in the recycling
and then the plastic part goes into the
trash okay perfect and it's okay if it's
crumpled it's just don't let it be
soiled right and when it goes through a
shredder also it makes the fiber shorter
it makes it less valuable as a
recyclable material so anything super
confidential shred it everything else
just do this
and put in your recycling bag Perfect
all right all right well we all just got
a little Greener thank you so much I
love you thank you guys for choosing to
spend your time with us we make this
show for you so take it with you thank
you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]